diverse desto besser das sollte für jede
gruppe gelten die einen lern datensatz
für ein training zusammenstellt denn
kommt eine sichtweise nicht vor
entstehen fehler das berichten auch die
forschungsgruppen der universität
kopenhagen
hassrede zu erkennen ist schwierig denn
manchmal ist es nur eine minderheit eine
bestimmte gruppe von menschen diese
erkennen kann wir haben beobachtet dass
es fälle gab wo sich alle einig war alle
bis auf eine person zb gab es eine
muslima und sie hat manche worte erkannt
mit denen immer abfällig über muslime
gesprochen wurde die anderen kannten die
gar nicht
ist eine gruppe nicht repräsentiert
entwickelt die vorurteile dazu kommt
eine ki lernt ständig weiter wenn also
im netz einige gruppen weniger
wortmeldungen haben als der rest denkt
die ki deren meinungen seien minderheits
meinungen
zb in den virtuellen räumen in denen es
viel frauenfeindlichkeit gibt melden
sich frauen natürlich weniger zu wort
die ki denkt dann das ansichten die
geschlechtergerechte bezahlung
extremistisch sein weil diese ansichten
ebendort komfort kommen
deswegen arbeitet eine forschungsgruppe
der universität in einer k die alle
menschen online fair behandelt ein
algorithmus soll hassrede im netz
erkennen ohne dabei eine bestimmte
gruppe zu diskriminieren
doch das ist nicht leicht inhalte im
netz sind oft nicht eindeutig
schlagworte für das training dieser ki
zu erstellen ist schwierig
ein beispiel könnte ich hier sein ich
hasse alle den wir haben hier eine liste
mit identitäten den englische menschen
das kann alles mögliche sein und dann
vergeben wir verschiedene kategorien ist
das verletzend gegenüber einer
bestimmten identität und in welche
richtung geht es ist es allgemein oder
geht es um eine bestimmte person um mich
bis der algorithmus fertig entwickelt
ist wird es noch einige monate dauern
firmen wie facebook könnten in zukunft
von solchen modellen profitieren